we in the principal chroniclers of the
rise of anti-americanism all around the
world since 2002 we've we've conducted
165 thousand inch reviews and we've in
60 nations and we've observed the ways
in which American policies the American
Pro approach has alienated many people
around the world and brought the esteem
of the United States down in many places
well it's it's pretty low and in
we've just did a survey of 45 countries
and in 33 of these countries we have
trends since 2002 and the image the
favorable ratings the United States have
declined in in 25 of these 34 three
countries and the image of the United
States and Western Europe is quite low I
mean in Germany in 2002 78 percent
favorable today it's 30 percent
favorable in Spain it's only 21 percent
of 25 percent something like that and in
the Muslim world it's abysmal I mean not
only is the United States disliked it's
literally hated and the image unites the
American people have have taken somewhat
of a hit too and trying to say that
Americans are hated in Europe but the
American people and the American Way is
that not as popular as it once was and
there's great concern these days about
American power which is a consequence of
dislike of American policies were the
sole superpower that wasn't a problem
throughout the 90s when it wasn't
concerned about our policies but it is a
concern now that much of the world
thinks the United States goes its own
way decides to do what wants to do
without soliciting the views of its
allies or the ascent of international
organizations
well the Iraq Wars is the poster child
for disliking American policies but in
the Middle East American policies with
respect to Israel and and the
Palestinians is is also a very big issue
I think those are the major ones and you
know they affect Iraq in particular
affects how much support through our
four other things
support for the war in Afghanistan which
was generally very strong is now going
down and much of Europe public's divided
about whether there should be German and
French troops in Afghanistan these polls
are presenting a picture of reactions to
America as the dominant nation in the
world at this particular point in
history they're in a sense providing the
kind of feedback that Rome never got hey
you have to go back to Rome to get a
country to have a point in history where
one country was such a dominant part of
of them that what was known as the known
world one of the other things that our
recent polls show is the well there's
not a lot of confidence in the United
States and all that comes in China
people are worried about the power of
China too and they're the Russians of
Putin in particular turn people off and
there's a great discontent with the
powers that be and I think that's in
part because for many years since the
fall of the Soviet Union people around
the world have looked to the United
States as
as the country that will help shape how
we manage global issues and global order
to use an old term and now there's not
that because the United States is not
trusted but but no one else is trusted
in Europe there's the EU but that's
different than another country
you